when people talk about nurturing
students to be future ad they always
talk about technology artificial
intelligence and all that to me
technology is a given it's a really
morality a big part of our lives what's
missing is actually the humanity in us
how humane are we
we met Alice in one of our community
involvement programs Alice had a stroke
that caused paralysis on her right arm
as a result her right hand is weaker
than her left hand she is having
difficulties in doing many things that
require her right hand how the bathing
students Hugh Maness is what's important
to us and this humanness must first come
from empathy which is the ability to
understand people who are different from
us when you work with people special
needs
you keep wanting to help them
but then we realized that she didn't
really want us to do that she kept
wanting to do things on her own to you
they look like they needed your help
even though they were struggling with it
but they actually wanted to do it on
their own empathy is what I like about
design thinking I like how this journey
or innovating and designing starts with
empathy everything needs to start from
entity do you really understand the
people you are serving I think she is
struggling to score up the last bit not
being able to scoop the last bits of
rice was really frustrating to her she
really wanted to do it on her own she
really didn't want people's help so we
thought it would be better if we could
help her eat on her own way let me tell
that a bit
Chikara where if we can create something
to help her turn the bowl I think she
can eat on that board that's a great
idea
mm I like Alice because she doesn't like
to waste food
she just wants to be independent you
know we might assume that she needs a
hat was everything but honestly I think
she doesn't want to help with anything
at all
[Music]
Anisa sneaks are very clear she has to
be able to finish up for all by herself
yeah otherwise she'll get quite
frustrated
you should come out if I talked about
the fight so that she can scope how cool
with me expand something like an iPad
stands for eligible on what about a
event a terrible table at mo that is
helpful where she wants it we we need a
tilting ball no let's make a touching
tree for tree that's opening angle
coming to us as well but how do you make
it tell guys have measured the world and
I'm gonna cut it
I will scoot over together how can I do
is
Phipps
ok let's try it I think it's time
[Music]
it's just a song Guinea tada tada
jamika annual Ruben the entire in the
heart of a new place shall I
[Music]
because she does eat
[Music]
at least we'll see hama guy she likes
throughout this whole journey if you
take away the technology if you just
focus on the human side design thinking
really taught us to be more empathetic
and kind to people the experience really
shaped our outlook of life we learn that
it's not just about expecting people to
be kind to us but rather asking
ourselves what we can do for others
[Music]
like we had so many problems with the
technology path we went into the project
knowing absolutely nothing about the
electric motor technology we did not
know what voltages we would need what
RPM or revolutions per minute stood for
however we learn everything along the
way by having the courage to step into a
star knowing that we knew nothing and
someone was going to get annoyed at us
for knowing nothing and we did not give
up because we knew that Alice was
waiting for us it produced as for her
and that motivated us now we know
kindness and empathy goes a long way we
don't have to be the most knowledgeable
people about things we just need to have
the motivation and drive to see it
through Design Thinking has made
learning more meaningful we never knew
what we learned in school could be so
useful in future so if we use our heart
to feel more to Pampa those more people
we can actually use our knowledge to
help more people
[Music]
you